two more out of control fires are on the
move in Southern California not far from
the scene of Wednesday's terrible mass
shooting the Woolsey fires what it's
called is burned dozens of homes and
threatened 30,000 more people in some
neighborhoods have been told to get out
John Blackstone is on the scene in Oak
Park that's northwest of Los Angeles
where firefighters are battling through
the night to save the homes there John
good morning to you good morning well
the battle is continuing in this
neighborhood we're 15 to 20 homes here
alone have already been destroyed and
across this fire some 30 homes at least
30 homes have been consumed the
conditions here are bone dry with
erratic winds gusting 25 to 55 miles an
hour Fanning the flames the intensifying
wolsey fire has quadrupled in size in
just hours firefighters are doing their
best to battle the raging flames as they
jump from one house to the next with
these high winds it's really hard with
the Ember cast that's happened it's
really hard for us to save these some of
these homes so what we're doing is
putting a water curtain in between some
homes to stop the fire from leapfrogging
and catching other homes on fire 30,000
people have been evacuated so far we
were there as flames over took another
Oak Park home despite firefighters
efforts big problem firefighters are
having here even when they think they
have this under control
embers fall on another house blown in by
these strong winds start another fire
the number of evacuate is expected to
rise as embers push ahead of the fire
one evacuation center was even forced to
close down as the flames spread and just
west of here another blazed up the hill
fire
top ten thousand acres yesterday
hundreds of firefighters are still
struggling to contain it
now this fire still burning but badly on
the hillsides here has meant complete
devastation for some homeowners and this
is really tragedy on top of tragedy here
because of course this is part of the
Thousand Oaks community which was the
scene of that mass shooting on Wednesday
night Oh Nora loved to hear that John
thank you